last month we saw the Israeli Army
invade Janine in maybe the largest
military invasion of Janine since 2002
um
and they killed many people they
attacked Medics and journalists and
brought daylight on camera they have
destroyed infrastructure and it was all
very painful but I think the most
compelling aspect
of the real engineering was what
followed Israeli soldiers at night held
their megaphones and uh
instructed hundreds of Palestinians to
flee their homes and they told them if
you don't leave if you don't have your
hand up in the air you will get shot and
they were forced to leave their homes in
the camp and walk to God knows where
I can guarantee you because the nakaba
is not that old I can guarantee you that
some people who were marching
away from their camps were chased away
from their homes in the camp engineering
were some of the same people who were
chased away from the homes in Haifa in
the first place this Perpetual exile
that Palestinian people
continue to live is is unbearable I mean
in my case my grandmother was removed
from her home in Haifa in 48 and then
she moved from City to city and then in
2009 she saw half of her home taken over
by Israeli soldiers my grandmother died
in 2020 and two months later we got the
next
expulsion order from the Israeli Court
I'm quite ashamed to admit
that I was relieved my grandmother had
died because I did not want her 102
years old at the time to go through yet
another
and this is the fact for so many
Palestinians regardless of where they
are on the map
if I may read the description of the
situation in Janine and maybe you can
comment so this is on July 3rd 4th and
5th
just reading Washington Post description
so this was an Israeli military
incursion to Janine The Raid included
more than one thousand soldiers backed
by drone strikes making it Israel's
largest such operation in the West Bank
since the end of the second Palestinian
Uprising in 2005.
the Israeli military said it dismantled
hundreds of explosive cleared hundreds
of weapons destroyed underground
hideouts and confiscated hundreds of
thousands of dollars in quote Terror
funds many of the 50 Palestinians who
have attacked Israelis since the start
of the year have come from Janine camp
and the surrounding area Palestinian
attacks inside Israel have killed 24
people this year U.N experts describe
the genie in operation as collective
punishment in quotes
for the Palestinian people amounting to
egregious violations of international
law many
of the more than 150 Palestinians killed
by Israelis this year have also come
from these communities Palestinian
Fighters say they need arms to defend
themselves against the Israeli
occupation and Military incursions into
the camp during which Palestinian
civilians including children have been
killed so those are the
I would say different perspectives
and the many people on both sides who
have been killed many more Palestinians
can you comment more about the situation
I mean I think the The Washington Post
article is a little bit more uh you know
careful than other than other media
that came out recently about Janine I
think you know I was listening to our
Reuters radio show and they failed to
ever mention the occupation I don't I
don't even think this paragraph
mentioned that Janine is under
occupation by the by the Israeli forces
by the Israeli regime I think this is
the most important piece of context that
gets
um obscured in our media reporting is
these cities these refugee camps are
under illegal occupation the Israeli
Army has no business being there in the
first place
um that is the most that is the
departure point that is the most
important piece of context that will
answer to you why these people
um are arming themselves many of which
by the way lived through the 2002
Massacre
um and bombardment of Janine and grew up
in the
um violence
um
the the context that Palestine is under
occupation that these Palestinian cities
are under occupation that they have to
deal with land seizures at all times
that they cannot leave their towns
um without a special permit all of this
will give context to the violence and
you know
the thousands of Israeli soldiers that
raided the camp that day
that traumatized an entire generation
they think they will quell that
generation they think that with such
Bloodshed and such barbaric violence
destroying infrastructure attacking
Medics killing people left and right
they think
with this kind of Terror that they can
you know quell people tell people that
you know they can guarantee that these
kids are not going to grow up and resist
but that's the opposite of what happens
one thing about Palestinian people
they will not compromise their dignity
you know these people live in
and he live in dire excruciating
circumstances
and it is so courageous in my opinion
that they even think
um to defend themselves against one of
the most lethal one of the most
sophisticated armies in the world
against the nuclear state that can wipe
them out in the matter of seconds but
it's not at the end of the day it's not
even about courage it's about survival
they don't do this because you know of
machismo or because of heroic Tendencies
it's because this is about survival
so the degree there's violence it's
about survival absolutely absolutely I
think if there is no if there was no
occupation there would be no violence
it's it's quite obvious and again people
understand this I mean like we saw on
Twitter in in the recent month uh all of
these Israeli uh propagandists who had
tweeted pictures of like little girls
with guns in Ukraine and like women
making bombs in Ukraine and and young
men carrying their rifles in Ukraine and
praising them as Heroes post very
similar pictures of Palestinians
um and calling them terrorists
it's glaring the double standard I don't
even need to linger on it well
the double standard is glaring but I
also think the glorification of violence
is questionable
there's a balance to be struck of course
but
yeah I mean I don't what I don't I don't
think I don't think we should be
glorifying violence
at all but I don't think we should be
normalizing violence either
uh uh I think that's that's that's what
it is you know I'll tell you a story
I was interviewing a person whose
brother was killed by the Israeli
military during uh Israeli raid
on their Village and
the person was so concerned about
whether I was going to report
that
her brother allegedly had a Molotov
cocktail in his hand
and I found it absolutely insane
absolutely
absurd that we can just glance over the
fact that there is again a foreign
military
in tanks with rifles and snipers
invading The Village at 4am in the
morning shooting live ammunition at
people's houses throwing tear gas that
we can just glance over it's normal we
could just report on it no problem
nobody's gonna badge an eyebrow
but
the fact that
potentially somebody might have picked
up a Molotov cocktail to throw it at
this invading Army is where we draw the
line it says a lot it says a lot about
whose violence is normalized is accepted
is institutionalized is
glorified event right then you walk
around Tel Aviv and you see all of the
plaques plastered around then around the
streets of the country of the city
celebrating the battles that they had
won the massacres that they had enacted
against the Palestinian people but God
forbid God forbid Palestinians have any
kind of similar sentiment
so on July 4th during this intense
period a Palestinian rammed a car into
pedestrians at a bus stop in Tel Aviv
injuring eight people before being shot
dead by a passerby
also that night Hamas fire rock is into
Israel and then Israel responded with
strikes on what it said was an
underground weapon site so just to give
some context to the intensives
violence happening here what do you
think about Hamas firing Rockets into
Israel
well it's the framing makes it seem as
though like
unprovoked Hamas is like firing Rockets
unto Israel regardless of what I think
of Hamas obviously but unprovoked but
that's not the case the propagation is
the fact that they are forced to live in
a cage
that they have no access to clean water
they have no access to basic rights no
access to uh Imports no access to
anything
that they can't leave their living in a
densely populated
Enclave that was deemed uninhabitable by
the U.N that was deemed an open air
prison
um so the rockets in any case are
retaliation for the seeds let's start
there but again this is just to prove my
point violence begets violence
Palestinian people are not violent
people we are not violent people at the
core and I think you know what serves
this narrative is islamophobia is like
xenophobia towards Arabs which we don't
have like I don't have the luxury you
know to like to write laws about
um by the way I'm I'm quite I'm quite
you know frustrated by this uh I am I am
preoccupied and the Palestinian people
are preoccupied
um with the material violence that we
have to deal with on the day-to-day the
demolitions the bombings uh the
imprisonment that's what we're
distracted with and and busy with that
we can't even talk about the racism
um The Casual racism against the
anti-palestinal racism being in the
media on social media and diplomatic
circles and but all of this all of this
racism that has gone unchecked has not
been regulated
um for decades allows for these tropes
to continue in which Palestinians are
promoted as these like barbaric
terrorists and the only way we could
remedy uh that situation is to is by
marketing them as these like defenseless
victims but the fact of the matter is
isn't is not this simplistic Palestinian
people are human beings who should enjoy
a full spectrum of humanity which in
includes raids which includes this day
which includes happiness and joy and
laughter which includes celebration
which includes
um all of these things but we're not
allowed this but we are doing exactly
what any people throughout history who
have been oppressed who have been
colonized who have been occupied have
done and continue to do as we see in
Ukraine which is celebrated by
mainstream media I'm sorry to uh keep
reiterating this point but
you know at this point uh
I am quite you know
exhausted by how exceptional Palestine
and Palestinian resistance is when the
world tells me time and time again that
it doesn't have a problem with violence
it just has a problem with who does that
violence